VIP part session in strasburg when m eps
will hear from angela merkel and cosmo
along the king of spain and in his High
Representative for foreign affairs and
security federica mogherini they are
also vote on payment services air
pollutants debate the outcome after
recently you zoom in on refugees and of
course the Volkswagen gates welcome to
the agenda history in the making when
Angela Merkel and Consuela address the
parliament side-by-side on wednesday
between the refugee crisis the decline
of the eurozone Greece Ukraine and the
possibility of British exit from the EU
there's no shortage of hot topics the
last time a German Chancellor and French
president delivered a speech together
was in 1989 right after the fall of the
Berlin Wall 26 years later the union
faces the prospect of new walls being
erected to hold back migrants the same
de filippis 6 king of spain will address
Parliament for the first time since he
became monarch last year when it's the
turn of federica mogherini address mep s
on syria and libya almost five years
after the Arab Spring the conflicts in
Libya and Syria worsened day by day tens
of thousands of fleeing most headed for
Europe the agreements made by member
states in September on how to relocate
120 thousand refugees mainly from Syria
will be the focus of a debate on Tuesday
EU leaders also reach 1 billion euros
per package for you an engine seized
dealing with the refugees in Lebanon
Jordan and Turkey we all know PayPal but
trust Lee or so forth like the US
counterpart they are online payment
services but European for the past 10
years online retail payment services
have increased hugely in the EU but
there's no specific legislation for them
mep s will correct that with a vote on
Thursday on a legal framework regulating
secure
standards customer data protection
Custer addiction and alluring room for
Europe based services to grow air
pollution has been on Europe's agenda
since the late 70s on Wednesday MEP s
will vote to limit the amount of harmful
products such as fine particles released
by medium-sized combustion plans there
are a hundred and fifty thousand of
these in the EU burning fuel for heat
power or steel production it hit the
automobile world like a hurricane news
of German carmaker Volkswagens global
emissions fixing scam on tues the mep is
will debate on mission measurements in
the car sector them in question being
how will the Commission move forward
stay tuned for an exciting session enjoy
unique
you